von wegen höheren tod die nato zeigt
sich lebendiger denn je auf ihrem gipfel
in madrid schweden und finnland werden
neue mitglieder das bündnis rückt damit
weiter an die russische grenze russland
wird als die größte gefahr für
sicherheit und frieden gesehen es werden
mehr soldaten in die östlichen staaten
verlegt abschreckung wird wieder groß
geschrieben präsident putin sieht das
offiziell nicht als bedrohung kündigt
aber spannungen mit den neuen
mitgliedern an was bedeutet das nun und
wie groß ist die gefahr einer eskalation
nato gipfel in madrid mehr mitglieder
mehr waffen um ihre stärke unser thema
in der phoenix runde
phoenix runde
putin hat geglaubt er könne das
transatlantische bündnis spalten und uns
schwächen aber er erntet genau das
gegenteil was er nicht wollte er wollte
die finalisierung der nato und er kriegt
jetzt die nato easy hrung von finnland
denken sie darüber nach
beiden heute in madrid auf seiner
pressekonferenz nach dem nato-gipfel
herzlich willkommen aus berlin ja reden
wir über die nato mit diesen gästen egon
ramms ist bei uns ehemaliger general der
nato für die bundeswehr nach seinem
ruhestand hat er als senior mentor für
die nato gearbeitet und kennt daher auch
unseren nächsten gast der uns
zugeschaltet ist aus estland rio terrace
er ist ehemaliger general und
oberbefehlshaber estland und inzwischen
ist er mitglied des europäischen
parlaments und ich begrüße rüdiger
lüdeking er ist botschafter adr war
unter anderem stellvertretender
beauftragter der bundesregierung für
abrüstung und rüstungskontrolle und auch
botschafter bei der osze und herzlich
willkommen angelika claußen die ist ko
vorsitzende der deutschen sektion der
internationalen ärzte und ärztinnen für
die verhütung des atomkriegs und diese
gesellschaft wurden 985 mit dem
friedensnobelpreis ausgezeichnet und so
lange sind sie auch schon dabei herr am
ist es war ein historischer gipfel haben
alle heute betont ein ganz besonderer
nato-gipfel die nato zeigt sich sehr
stark und begrüßt die neuen mitglieder
schweden und finnland und hat sich dazu
bekannt dass sie aufgenommen werden
sollen was ist ihr fazit von diesem
gipfel
dieser gipfel ist für mich etwas
überraschend vielleicht aber sicherlich
auch verursacht durch den druck den die
ukraine krieg auf die nato ausübt
ausgesprochen positiv verlaufen
das offensichtlich sehr sorgfältig
vorbereitet worden mit blick auf die
zukunft ich sehe einmal den beitritt
schweden und finnland als ein wichtiges
ergebnis dabei ich sehe die
geschlossenheit der nato staaten als
gewichtiges ergebnis dabei
und ich sehe auch die einigung auf ein
neues strategisches konzept als ein sehr
wichtiges ergebnis und solche
strategischen konzepte wirken ja auch
erheblich in die zukunft hinein also
sehr positiv herr terrors wie geht es
ihnen das baltikum
sie sind in estland hat besondere sorge
gegenüber wegen russland ist fühlen sie
sich jetzt etwas beruhigt danach diesem
nato gipfel
auf jeden fall ich bin einverstanden das
ist ein sehr guter gipfel war für meine
war mein geschmack war etwas zu spät ich
hätte gerne das gleiche schon in chicago
oder mindestens in mails seite oder male
babes gittern sehen wollen weil er schon
dann hatten
georgien hatten wir die ersten ukraine
krieg und wir haben da immer darüber
gesprochen
dass russland ein gefahr darstellt das
wohl die rüsten müssten müssten ukraine
noch mal angreifen um dann uns das
beizubringen dass das putin immer waffen
einsetzen will um die politische ziele
zu erreichen das gipfel ist sehr schnell
gelaufen sehr gut gelaufen sehr positiv
gelaufen ich bin auch fest überzeugt
dass durch finnland und schweden nato
stärker geworden ist und auch das ganze
ist sicherheitslage in und um den ostsee
sehr viel sich verbessert wenn die ihr
beitritt stattfindet das ist noch nicht
da wir müssen das auch noch sehen aber
aber ansonsten sehr gut gelaufen die
ersten sind natürlich
beruhigt aber wir sind immer ruhig
gewesen
wir müssen wir haben immer nur gesagt
dass wir auch die auf die gefahr lage
achten müssen und uns dafür wäre
vorbereiten müssen nato ist ein
verteidigungsbündnis und das müssen wir
jetzt tun und noch wesentlich besser aus
bist bist du okay also auch positiv frau
clausen wie sehen sie dass die nato die
sich ja sehr stark jetzt zeigt wo man
dann aber sagt die nato rückt eben
weiter nach russland machen sie sich
sorgen eine eskalation
ich mache mir große sorgen um eine
eskalation und die pmw das möchte ich
ganz klar betonen kritisiert in dem
neuen strategischen konzept der nato
dass die rolle von nuklearwaffen noch
stärker geworden ist als sie vorher
sowieso schon war und dass solche punkte
wie abrüstung und rüstungskontrolle
viel schwächer geworden sind und was wir
angesichts des ukraine krieges jetzt
brauchen und wo putin doch mit dem mit
der drohung atomwaffen einzusetzen auch
wenn das etwas unklar gelassen hat aber
diese drogen ist sehr sehr ernst zu
nehmen und da das ist doch auch eine art
völliger group und dann müsste die nato
doch sie können ja erst mal sagen wir
können uns nicht so schnell ändern aber
sie müssen doch darauf reagieren und
müssen doch hinweise und signale
aussenden das ist um eine diskussion der
rolle der nuklearwaffen geht und die
dieser ukraine krieg ist nicht durch
nukleare abschreckung verhindert worden
das ging gar nicht um gleichzeitig ist
die nato das größte rüstungsgeschäft
der rüstungsausgaben der welt werden von
nato-staaten und unterstützen sie denn
dass schweden und finnland jetzt teil
der nato werden wir
sehen das sehr kritisch auch unsere
sektion wir haben zwei sektionen in
finnland und in schweden die haben
dagegen gekämpft so lange es ging haben
aber gesagt
die bevölkerung ist so dass möchten und
wir werden uns dem nicht widersetzen was
sie aber
gleichzeitig sehr klar fordern von ihren
jeweiligen regierungen ist dass schweden
und finnland ihre anti nukleare
tradition bewahren dass sie also keine
atomwaffen stationieren sollen auf ihrem
gelände und also auf ihrem territorium
und eben auch nicht der nuklearen
planungsgruppe
beitreten und insofern könnte es auch
eine stärkung der kritischen
staaten geben die sich zu geradezu
nuklearer
abschreckung hessen.de lüdeking wenn man
jetzt dass die nato stärker wird das
schweden und finnland dazu kommen ist
das sozusagen jetzt eine größere chance
für die diplomatie und für eine
möglichkeit diesen konflikt mit der
ukraine anders zu beenden oder ist damit
die chance für die diplomatie viel viel
schlechter geworden wenn ich nur ganz
kurz mal auf das vielleicht reagieren
darf was vor klaus gesagt hat ich stimme
der bewertung von drums vollständig zu
es war ein erfolgreicher gipfel und die
nato hat sich ja seit den 60er jahren
seitdem per mail konzept von 164 ist
1967 eine doppelstrategie
vorgenommen nämlich dass man bereit ist
zu dialog zur zusammenarbeit aber das
voraussetzung ist dass man eine
gesicherte verteidigungsfähigkeit hat
und da hat es mängel gegeben und dieser
nato gipfel ist für meine begriffe ein
wichtiges element gewesen ein wichtiges
event gewesen nicht nur im hinblick auf
den ukrainer konflikt sondern überhaupt
wir haben uns zu lange auf den auf den
den ausgeruht in der und es geht um die
selbstbehauptung nicht nur des
westlichen bündnisses sondern auch und
das hoffe ich dass das also auch jetzt
wenn man so will ein follow up gibt auf
europäischer ebene wir müssen auch uns
auf europäischer ebene besser
verteidigungspolitisch organisieren das
heißt das was makro als
strategische autonomie ausgegeben hat
als als messe das sollten wir
realisieren denn es geht wirklich um
eine neue sicherheitslage in der wir uns
befinden
ganz offen gesagt
wie lange können wir auf usa als den
berechenbaren partner setzen natürlich
wir wollen die usa das ist wenn sie
einmal in der diplomatie anfangen dann
gibt es zwei dinge die sie sofort lernen
erstens die bedeutung des
transatlantischen verhältnisses und
zweitens die bedeutung der europäischen
einigung und daran hängen wir auch aber
man muss sich in einer multilateralen
rüstungs konkurrenz oder einer rivalität
zwischen den großmächten muss sich
europa besser
positionieren okay ganz gut wir vorwärts
zu den terrassen eine sekunde therapie
wird ganz ganz kurz noch mal die
nachfrage weil ich sie am anfang gefragt
aber gibt es eine chance für die
diplomatie oder ist sie durch diese
nato-gipfel schwächer geworden ich
glaube dass die chance eigentlich etwas
stärker geworden ist wenn natürlich und
das ist eigentlich mein mann mein mann
mein beschweren ist dass man also auf
die diplomatie in den letzten wochen und
monaten nicht gesetzt hat und es ist
meiner ansicht zynisch wenn man einfach
alles laufen lässt die ganzen tausenden
zehntausenden von opfern in kauf nimmt
jetzt eventuell wenn man so will
kollateralschäden hat in form von
hungertoten in der dritten welt das kann
man nicht einfach so laufen lassen da
muss etwas auch passieren auf
diplomatischer ebene der terrasse
wollten reagieren
ja ich wollte einfach sagen dass man
nicht vergessen muss dass es nicht nato
ist eskaliert hat die eskalation kommt
nicht von seite der nato
fast 30 jahren hat nato
versucht mit russland zu sprechen es
waren unterschiedliche verträge rüstungs
abrüstungsverträge da die alle von
russland weggeworfen worden sind und und
positiv steht nur stärke
wir haben versucht eiskunstlaufen und wo
die werbung zu machen aber er hat immer
hobby eishockey gespielt und ich glaube
dass gerade sind wird dabei wieder unser
eishockey gehen zusammen
zusammenzustellen und ein dialog braucht
eben zwei seiten und heute sehe ich
keinen schickt von von russischen seite
für ein dialog er versteht nur stärke
und 1
provoziert nur ihn wieder zweite zu
machen das ist was 2014 in ukraine dann
hören wir mal direkt was putin gesagt
hat wir spielen kurz seine noten an von
präsident putin von gestern abend in
turkmenistan hat er reagiert auf den
dann möglichen beitritt von schweden und
finnland
mit nico stunden das mal darüber wie spa
wir haben kein problem damit dass
finnland und schweden nato-mitglieder
werden wenn sie wollen dann bitte schön
aber sie sollten klar verstehen das ist
für sie vorher keine bedrohung gar ein
genie rollen die kugeln dort jetzt aber
nato truppen stationiert werden und
infrastruktur eingerichtet wird dann
müssen wir in gleicher weise reagieren
und dieselbe bedrohungen schaffen die
von diesem gebiet für uns ausgeht
dieselbe bedrohung schaffen wie muss ich
das verstehen herr hans
leute ich mir putin geht offensichtlich
davon aus dass die nato ihnen gedroht
was aufgrund der gesamten geschichte der
nato
von 1949 bis heute nicht der fall
gewesen ist wurde gerade schon
angesprochen die nato ist ein
verteidigungsbündnis und die nato schutz
das territorium und da hat die absicht
das wurde jetzt auch bei dem gipfel noch
mal bekräftigt das territorium ihrer
mitgliedstaaten zu schützen
die nato hat noch nie einen krieg
angefangen und von daher sage ich mal
hat die nato bisher die balance gefunden
und wir dürfen nicht in dieses
selbstbestimmungsrecht der länder
eingreifen indem wir irgend ein land
welches einen solchen beitrittsantrag
stellt diesen beitritt verweigern ich
rufe rio terrace mit als zeugen auf
die ersten die letten die litauer
vorher schon die polen und andere länder
die im osten von deutschland liegen oder
ostwärts mitteleuropa liegen haben den
schutz der nato gesucht und die nato
mitglieder geworden einfach weil sie aus
der vergangenheit und aus der erfahrung
heraus angst furcht vor dem russischen
bären gehabt haben und sie haben diese
angst auch zu recht gab wenn man sich
die geschichte russlands oder vor der
sowjetunion in russland betrachtet dann
hat er russland immer versucht eine
bestimmte einflussnahme über die
russland umgebenden länder wahrzunehmen
oder durchzuführen und das kann auf die
dauer kann das nicht hingenommen werden
und ich möchte noch mal erinnern an die
jahre diese zehn jahre die wir mit jens
hin gehabt haben wir haben ja alle
möglichen verträge abgeschlossen
rein bilateral bezogen auf muster in die
ukraine hat jelzin mit kuba einen
vertrag abgeschlossen
im jahre 1997 der durch die beiden
parlamente entsprechend ratifiziert
worden ist das heißt es gab eine völlig
gesicherte grundlage für die integrität
der grenzen für die unverletzlichkeit
der grenzen von der ukraine können ohne
dann auch wenn ich dann an die
budapester konvention denke nach dem
abzug der nuklearwaffen aus der ukraine
der weg verlegt worden sind da war
russland sogar garantiemacht da kann ich
nur sagen auf eine solche garantie macht
kann ich gerne verzichten wenn die dann
hinterher anfang dieses land wo sie die
sicherheit garantiert dann anzugreifen
wie sehr empfinden sie das als drohung
bei mir da putin gerade gehört haben
welche sorgen machen sie sich da ich
mache mir in bezug auf putin sehr große
sorgen und herr putin hat ja auch den
also letztes letzte woche hat der erste
überprüfungs vertrag des atomwaffen
verbots vertrages stattgefunden wo ich
auch selber anwesend war wo auch die
vertreter der deutschen regierung
anwesend waren also mehrere überall
beobachterstaaten aus der nato und der
deutsche vertreter hat ein konstruktives
statement dort macht herr putin hat
diesen atomwaffen verbots vertrag
herunter bekannt zählt muss man ganz
ganz deutlich sagen
und sowas gibt natürlich auch kein
vertrauen gleichwohl finde ich die
bisherige einschätzung also von herrn
rams zu einseitig die nato ist jetzt ja
nun auch nicht nur lieb und die usa ist
auch nicht nur lieb trump hat in seiner
regierungszeit in ihren vertrag
gekündigt und trump hat auch den vertrag
über den offenen himmel gekündigt das
ging von eindeutig von der regierung
trump aus und nicht von der russischen
regierung und es hat meines erachtens
auch immer wieder möglichkeiten gegeben
die man hätte aufgreifen können also
satz wir haben das ist dass man russland
dann auch falsch behandelt hat
ich will jetzt nicht sagen dass putin
anders geworden wäre oder dass er dann
den überfall und den einmarsch in die
ukraine nicht gemacht hätte das weiß
kein mensch aber ich finde es ist
wichtig auch eine gewisse selbstkritik
an der eigenen politik zu äußern und
abrüstung und rüstungskontrolle sind
auch von seiten der nato vernachlässigt
worden und die sind eben jetzt
wird das ist es auch nicht an erster
stelle ohne darum geht es in zug hätte
das was geändert
ja ich glaube schon also ich meine da
muss ich ihnen zustimmen es geht nicht
nur um abrüstungskontrolle sondern wir
haben seit etwa 2000 seit auch dem
amtsantritt von bush junior in
washington eine andere politik der
amerikaner gegenüber russland wir hatten
ja ganz zu beginn
auch nach dem ende des kalten kriegs
sehr viel getan um die sorgen die
russland geäußert hat was die sicherheit
russlands angeht was das das glacis
angeht was es beansprucht hat dem also
entsprechend das ist dann weggefallen
das ist also glaube ich auch ein teil
des hochamtes denen wir teilweise im
westen hatten und das ist sehr
bedauerlich gleichzeitig muss ich aber
auch sagen dass natürlich das was jetzt
putin gemacht hat in keiner weise zu
rechtfertigen ist also es gibt überhaupt
keinen grund das zu rechtfertigen oder
zu entschuldigen sondern das ist halt
und wir müssen uns nur halt klar werden
darüber was wir vielleicht versäumt
haben in der vergangenheit und das sind
große versäumnisse gleichzeitig will ich
aber auch noch mal eines sagen ich
glaube wenn man jetzt abrüstung und
rüstungskontrolle das ist dann das darf
man nicht verwechseln mit etwas was dann
die friedliebenden machen wollen das ist
für mich integraler bestandteil der
sicherheitspolitik
aufrüstung jetzt ja jetzt sogar wir
müssen jetzt natürlich auch für uns der
der zeitpunkt gekommen wo wir erst mal
unsere verteidigungsfähigkeit
wiederherstellen müssen und jetzt auch
nicht der zeitpunkt gekommen abzurücken
gleichzeitig will ich aber auch sagen
was mich gestört hat ist dieses dieser
polizist muss der in vielen erklärungen
zum ausdruck kommt auch von politikern
und die ja
das herunterspielen der eskalation
risiken die tatsächlich da sind und ich
würde das also durchaus auch sagen es
gibt ein eskalation risiko dass besteht
dass auch wenn dann vor allen dingen
verschärft bestehen wird wenn putin sich
an die ecke gedrängt fühlt oder mit dem
rücken zur wand steht dass er dann
vielleicht als letztes element
vielleicht sich sogar noch überlegt
nuklearwaffen einsetzen und das wird für
meine begriffe viel zu sehr unterschätzt
bei uns herr terrors wie sehr sehen sie
die das was putin der sarg wie empfinden
sie das sie kennen ja auch seine worte
gegenüber dem baltikum also wie sehr
muss oder was meint er damit wenn er
sagt wir müssen dann überlegen wie wir
reagieren
ganz ehrlich ich finde es sehr naiv zu
denken dass putin anderes gehandelt
hätte wenn er wenn wir uns irgendwie
besser zu ihm
hätten
wenn wir besser gewesen wären zu
russland weil sein erstes
eintritt
[Musik]
hatten erst zweite tschetschenienkrieg
den ganzen stadt großen linien
vernichtet genauso wie mario heute
oder aleppo in syrien das heißt ist
immer das gleiche gewesen und sein sein
ziel ist russland größer zu machen es
ist ein imperiales kolonialkrieg was er
führt für die ressourcen und ihn
interessiert diese verträge was jetzt
irgendwann irgendwo unterschrieben hat
überhaupt nicht ich bin selbst auch
mehrmals in russland gewesen als jene
wiener dokument kontrolle und ich wusste
schon damals dass für die russen das
einfach ein blatt papier ist was was die
überhaupt nicht wichtig gefahren und
aber um den nuklearen krieg ich würde
sagen die bedrohung ist immer da deshalb
ist auch wichtig dass wir dass die
nuklearen abschreckung immer noch in
unserem koffer ist aber ich glaube auch
jena wird nicht zulassen dass russland
mit mitleid mit diesen spielzeugen
spielen china ist heute hinter hinter
putin aber aber wenn da wenn putin da
anfängt mit mir zu spielen wo jeder sich
gar nicht so stark fühlt dann dann
werden die chinesen schon
auch dazu etwas sagen wollen und deshalb
denke ich dass die nukleare kriegs
möglichkeit heute nicht da ist da sehen
sie das will ich aber nicht man sollte
es aber nicht zu sehr herunterspielen
ich glaube wenn putin an der wand steht
kein wenn sein eigenes überleben auf dem
spiel steht das überleben seines regimes
dann ist eine eskalation sowie
horizontal wie auch vertikal nicht
auszuschließen ich glaube das wird immer
heruntergespielt das halte ich für
unverantwortlich das hat nichts mit
ängstlichkeit zu tun das schlicht
unverantwortlich
noch einmal will ich aber zusagen dann
nochmal wie sollte man danach damit
umgehen wenn sie sagen dass es der
unfall nie was wäre dann
verantwortliches handeln dann ja das ist
eben die große frage und da sehe ich
natürlich dass auch die bundesregierung
zwischen celle und charybdis
in einem dilemma steckt einerseits haben
wir eine moralische verpflichtung
die ukraine zu unterstützen gleichzeitig
wollen wir aber auch verhindern eine
eskalation die vielleicht zu einem
nuklearkrieg führt der natürlich
existenziell ist da geht es nicht nur um
zerstörung sondern geht es um wenn sie
wollen das ist ein großes wort um das
überleben der menschheit und da muss man
also sehr vorsichtig agieren und
manchmal habe ich das gefühl wenn ich
das ganz ehrlich sagen da soll das in
amerika ist eine weniger aufgeladene
debatte als hier teilweise hier haben
wir halt das große problem dass wir
einerseits den moralischen anspruch
haben die moralische argumentation die
mit großen mit großer wärme vorgetragen
wird und gleichzeitig fehlt mir manchmal
das augenmaß das natürlich realpolitisch
erforderlich ist um zu einem ende des
krieges zu kommen und das ist das ziel
aus meiner sicht dass auch jetzt zum
beispiel heute ist ja auch dieser aufruf
veröffentlicht worden in der zeit
waffenstillstand jetzt das treibt diese
leute um wir sind natürlich in einer
situation wo die einkaufs redaktions
risiken tendenziell vielleicht steigen
lassen und dann sie ich möchte zu zwei
sachen stellung nehmen wir haben einen
ganz konkreten aufruf gemacht am anfang
des ukrainisch krieges und haben
dafür eine million unterschriften
gesammelt
news
von also kein erster kann erst einsatz
von atomwaffen im ukraine krieg und das
eben gemeinsam die usa und russland
diesen no firstnews appell
unterschreiben sollen das ist natürlich
erstmal eine erste initiative das ist
mir klar dass uns darauf uns allen klar
dass das jetzt nicht sofort passiert
aber es ist wichtig dass wir als
friedensbewegung diese forderung
überhaupt wieder auf den tisch legen und
wir sind mit diesen über eine million
unterschriften zu der un gehen
vertretenden generalsekretären gegangen
frau camille zu haben die übergeben und
ihr vorschlag ist das im sicherheitsrat
eine anhörung stattfinden sollte wo über
die humanitären folgen eines begrenzten
auch begrenzten atomkriegs gesprochen
wird damit es einfach mal öffentlich
wird und
länder die das zum beispiel jetzt als
mitglieder einbringen könnten während
mexiko und auch die schweiz und ich
würde mich sehr freuen wenn die
bundesregierung damit der schweiz
kontakt aufnehmen würde und diese
initiative eben von von der seite oder
überhaupt auch mit unterstützen würde
der bund zudem nur fuß möchte ich noch
sagen china hat
2021 im spätherbst hat selber gesagt
dass sie bereit sind ein vize außen oder
vize verteidigen zu können dass das weiß
ich nicht mehr genau dass sie bereit
sind ein no firstnews appell zu machen
wenn alle fünf statt alle atommächte im
sicherheitsrat damit machen das kann man
natürlich nicht alleine machen aber auch
solche wie die einer dass man das mit
russland jetzt noch machen kann es geht
nicht darum zu fragen ist finde ich eine
falsche frage ob man das jetzt mit
russland machen kann es geht darum dass
wir überhaupt diese dinge wieder
besprechen dass sie in die diplomatie
kommen und es könnten ja zum beispiel
gespräche erfolgen gespräche die auf die
minderung der nuklearen risiken gerade
zwischen den usa und zwischen rußland
ausgerichtet sind dazu gibt es eine
entsprechende expertengruppe die das
gehen also das ist ihr punkt ganz so ich
glaube herr terrace sie wollten da noch
gerade was zu sagen und dann heran
ich wollte einfach sagen diese diese
geräte liebe die
waffenstillstand ich glaube schon dass
es wichtig wäre wenn wir dazu kommen
werden aber die einzigen die darüber
stimmen müssen sind die ukraine die
jeden tag gekauft werden und sterben und
ich glaube auch dass die frau klaus und
recht hat dass die nukleare gespräche
weiter geführt werden müssten aber heute
ist der priorität dass sie mitten in
europa putin zivile bevölkerung getötet
massenweise und wir wie fange langsam
das zu vergessen und haben andere themen
kommen ihn ich weiß dass demokratie
fluglehrer krieg schlecht ist aber heute
ist schon ein krieg da wo die ganzen
städte
ausrangiert werden und damit wissen wir
was anfangen da helfen nur hoffen das
heißt europa muss sich zu sagen tun und
viel mehr waffen ukrainische brahms ist
das ein punkt wo man sagt wir müssen
erst den ukraine krieg irgendwie
befrieden bevor wird uns dann um die
nukleare abrüstung kümmern müssen oder
muss man das gleichzeitig immer denkt
also ich bin lüdeking einer meinung dass
diplomatie auch in kriegszeiten weiter
gehen muss und dass man sich mit den
gegner mit anderen unterhalten muss um
bestimmte ziele zu erreichen nur wir
müssen das so einschätzen dass wladimir
putin dieses im augenblick und in den
letzten jahren vielen jahren sogar wo
wir hätten vielleicht schon vorher
reagieren können und diese themen hätten
aufgreifen können
zu solchen themen nicht an den tisch
gekommen ist wenn ein jump den vertrag
gekündigt hat dann muss man halt eben
auch als hintergrund dahinter legen dass
putin das heißt russland zu diesem zeit
neue waffensysteme mit einer reichweite
von mehr als 500 kilometern entwickelt
hatte und aus dem grunde den vertrag
nicht gekündigt aber gebrochen hat das
ist eine ganz einfache tatsache so und
wenn ich dann vertragspartner bin dann
überlege ich mir wie ich meinem vertrags
gegenüber signalisiere dass ich mit
seiner vorgehensweise nicht
einverstanden bin ich bin kein tropfen
in aller deutlichkeit gesagt aber da
muss man die sache schon mal richtig
sitzen lassen auch zu ihrer ansage mit
dem jahr 2000 george bush ich möchte
doch darauf hinweisen dass polen
ungarn und die tschechische republik
bereits im jahr 1999 da war damit noch
nicht bestimmt nicht im amt mit die
ersten länder waren die nato erweiterung
für sich beantragt gewünscht und
bekommen haben und die balken haben
damals getrauert das weiß ich aus
eigener erfahrung weiß ich da nicht beim
ersten schub mit dabei waren sondern
erst im märz 2004 in die nato
aufgenommen wurden ich habe gefahren der
baltische staaten im hauptquartier in
stettin am flaggenmast hochgezogen
damals um diese in aller deutlichkeit zu
sagen von daher wir reden über das was
wir uns wünschen das ist richtig richtig
wir reden über das was wir mit
diplomatie und politik erreichen können
vielleicht wir müssen aber heute reden
und dann gebe ich rege terrace völlig
recht wir müssen aber heute reden über
das was in der ukraine passiert und da
sterben jeden tag hunderte von menschen
durch diese aggression von putin und das
ist realität das ist schlicht und
einfach hin und her dass das jetzt erst
da müssen wir uns als erstes darum
kümmern ich sage doch das soll nicht
sagen hätten aber geht nur mit schweren
waffen das sagen sie auch das geht nur
in schweren waffen das sehen sie andere
würde ich auch an nachher
umso anfangs so manchmal dieser punkte
die aber es gibt eine ganze reihe von
punkten auf die ich eigentlich gerne
eingehen würde das erste ist das ein
gutes beispiel bei der ersten nato
erweiterung hat es ein vorspiel gegeben
nämlich in form dass die nato russland
grundakten also auch bestimmte
verpflichtungen zurückhaltung
verpflichtungen die die nato übernommen
hat übrigens auch
ja russland hat ja nie russland hat dann
sogar 99 bei dem osze-gipfel auch eine
verpflichtung
übernommen für den militär bezirk
leningrad software speziell
also es hat da etwas gegeben das hat es
hinterher nicht mehr gegeben insofern
muss ich sagen waren wir etwas blauäugig
naiv in der art und weise wie wir auf
russland reagiert haben und ich will ja
nicht jetzt die ganze geschichte wieder
erzählen aber 2007 war ja deutlich was
putin davon gehalten hat das seine
interessen nicht berücksichtigt wurden
und im übrigen würde ich auch sagen die
nuklearwaffen so schön so so sehr wir
uns auch dafür eingesetzt haben und
einsetzen sollten dass sie ab gerüstet
sind man kann sich gar nicht vorstellen
was einen nuklearkrieg auch selbst ein
begrenzter nuklearkrieg der im übrigen
auch von von trump als möglichkeit
durchaus ins auge gefasst worden ist was
er anrichtet aber ich fürchte dass jetzt
wo russland aus dem krieg geschwächt
hervorgehen wird dass russland viel mehr
noch auf die nuklearwaffen wert legen
wird als vorher es sind kleine
nuklearstrategie ford vor zehn jahren
geändert hat in dieser richtung mit dem
taktischen nuklearwaffen die eingesetzt
werden sollen wie gefechtsfeld
artillerie da steht ihnen der eindruck
wir denn heute ja gut ich meine das ist
auch die frage haben wann ich mein lied
ist natürlich die füllten novosti es ist
natürlich eine deklaratorisch und man
hat sich natürlich auch gegenüber
amerika daten dazu erklärt auch von
europäischer seite auch von deutscher
seite nur weiß ich dass zum beispiel die
mittelosteuropäischen staaten das nicht
haben wollten sie wollten also keine
reduzierung der rolle der nuklearwaffen
dreimal war dann noch einmal bei dem
beim ukraine konflikt um zu gucken wie
man da weiterkommen verpassen weil sie
wollten das gerne mal aus und warum hat
etwas sagen sie sagen keine schweren
waffen das ist ja dass die ganze etwas
die ukraine so stark fordert immer
wieder um russland zurückzudrängen warum
sind sie dagegen warum wollen sie der
ukraine nicht auf diese art helfen wir
sind eine friedensorganisation und wir
sind
wir sind nicht befugt in diese art der
schweren waffen zu bewerten und ob sie
denn unbedingt zur kriegsführung nötig
sind gleichwohl ist doch jede alle
schweren waffen die geschickt werden
bedeuten doch letztlich und ich denke es
ist ein stellvertreterkrieg in denen die
ukraine jetzt übergegangen ist bedeuten
ja immer mehr waffen immer mehr schwere
waffen immer tollere immer
weitreichendere raketenwerfer bedeuten
doch und ich sehe dass es alleine
gemacht wird das ist keine kleine
anstrengung gibt gleichzeitig für
diplomatie und das finde ich sehr sehr
einseitig und zu glauben dass man in
einem zermürbungskrieg dann wie endet
man denn da wie viele wie viele
wie viel zivilbevölkerung soll dennoch
sterben in der ukraine
wie viele städte sollen noch zerbombt
werden wie viele ukrainische soldaten
sollen noch sterben wie viele russische
soldaten sollen noch sterben das sind
doch alle sehen sie denn ein ansatz
solange putin nicht verhandeln will das
ist das große problem dar da ist ja so
langsam ist das schon mal ausprobiert
weil ich das wort verloren ich würde
aber gerne
meine schlussfolgerung noch sagen in der
friedens- und konfliktforscher wird
gesagt dass man nach übergeordneten
zielen suchen muss um zu gucken ob da
zunächst einmal gewisse gemeinsame also
ob über verhandlung ziele auch zu
ende gebracht werden können und verfolgt
werden können und da wäre zum beispiel
die hungerkrise schon ein wichtiges ziel
was gemeinsam verfolgt werden könnte was
allen helfen würde das intro noch
viel mehr getan werden könnte und es
könnte gleichzeitig auch es könnten doch
angebote kommen von seiten der nato von
seiten auch der usa die mit am tisch
sitzen muss dass eine bereitschaft da
ist zu reden also ohne
der krieg jetzt sofort auf da bin ich
mehr heran sie wollten also man kann das
was frau klose gerade gesagt in zwei
teile teilen und auch von zwei seiten
sehen
der erste punkt die nicht festhalten
möchte ist dass sich auf dem eu-gipfel
und bei dem g7 gipfel die dort
vertretenen staaten darauf geeinigt
haben nahrungsmittelhilfe zu leisten für
den süden der weltkugel um dieses zum
teil mit erheblichen beträgen und dass
sich die europäische union zurzeit darum
bemüht auf verhandlungswege oder wie
auch immer getreide aus der ukraine
rauszukriegen und dieses in den süden
der welt entsprechend verteilen zu
können das heißt man kann den ländern
nicht vorwerfen dass sie sich mit diesem
problem nicht beschäftigt haben wie weit
wir punkten dass gemacht hat weiß ich
nicht zweite anmerkung funktion ist der
aggressor russland ist der aggressor
gegen die ukraine mit einer nahezu
einjährigen vorbereitung die wir gesehen
haben die wir aber nicht genutzt haben
in dieser richtung einmal nicht genutzt
haben für verhandlungen einmal nicht
genutzt haben für möglicherweise das
zeigen militärischer stärke um ihn
aufzuhalten welche mittel man da auch
immer einsetzt nur das problem ist die
tatsache dass im kern diese aggression
das problem ist und wenn ich dann sage
ich gebe dir der ukraine keine schweren
waffen dann heißt das in der konsequenz
dass sich die ukraine gegenüber russland
opfere und das kann nicht in unserem
interesse liegen wenn wir den ukrainer
keine nach diesem keine munition mehr
geben ist für die der krieg irgendwann
zu ende weil sie keine eigene
rüstungsindustrie mehr haben das heißt
dann computing zu dem ziel mit dem er am
angefangen hatten mit lokal zu
überrollen dann wird er die ukrainische
bevölkerung russland einverleiben oder
deportieren was er zum teil jetzt schon
macht kinder werden von ihren familien
getrennt und dergleichen dinge mehr das
kann doch keine sache sein die wir
unterstützen können sondern müssen wir
nach unserem verständnis werte recht
humanitäre regeln der gleich mehr müssen
wir versuchen eine grenze zu setzen aber
dann wenn wir das nicht tun hat falsch
aber sehr gefährlich ist zu sagen das
müssen die amerikaner und russen an
tisch sitzen und darüber handeln was aus
der ukraine das hat man schon in der
geschichte der fiel mehrmals gesehen und
das ist nicht was wir wollen und das
dürften wenig tun das ist ein
talent ist ein demokratisch gewählte
präsident die haben meine eine ein
parlament der demokratisch gewählt ist
für die für die eu zu stehen und wenn
wie die jetzt im stich lassen und denen
nicht das gehen was die am meisten
brauchen nämlich dreimal gesagt waffen
waffen waffen dann dann haben dann haben
wir ein land 40 millionen die eigentlich
für europa sehr wichtig ist und
eigentlich auch ein vorteil wäre wenn
ukraine teil wäre bei der teil der
europäischen union wäre und wenn wir die
nicht heute helfen dann werden wir eine
regierung schaffen die gegen europäische
union ist auch kann man die musik und
vielleicht die nato hat ja klar gesagt
dass sie hilft das ist ein ganz klarer
punkt und das schweden und finnland
jetzt dazu sind worden richtige
waffenlieferung estland hat heute mehr
mehr haubitzen 3 an die ukraine
geschickt aus deutschland versprochen
und innovation sind klein
gewinnen
nur ganz kurz noch dazu also man will
natürlich keinen falschen präsident
verschaffen und den schafft man wenn man
die ukraine alleine lässt und dann
russland seine kriegsziele erreicht auf
der anderen seite muss man natürlich
auch realistisch sein man muss sehen was
können denn wir mit unseren
waffenlieferungen erreichen im optimalen
fall und da ist das problem dass
vielfach die ziele die in der westlichen
politik verfolgt werden gar nicht klar
sind also wollen wir dass die ukraine
die
besetzten gebiete wieder
besetzen kann wieder erobern kann wie
weit soll das gehen soll das nur der
dornbach sein soll dass eventuell auch
dann die krim sein ich glaube man sollte
da sehr vorsichtig sein dass man da
nicht zu große erwartungen weg denn das
sind waffenlieferungen die
wahrscheinlich gar nicht
getätigt werden können
ich weiß jetzt nicht wie man es nennen
sollte das ist ja ein 1 1
diskussionen was heißt denn sieg war
soll soll nicht verlieren soll bestehen
also ich würde schon sagen man muss da
etwas vorsichtiger sein um nicht allzu
große erwartungen zu wecken denn das
geht natürlich realpolitisch auf etwas
zu wo man wirklich sagen muss sorry dass
ich so sagen so offen sage die für die
russen dürfte eine rückgabe der krim
nicht akzeptabel seien und das hat das
sagen auch leute die navalny hatte sich
mal dazu geäußert also man muss auch
sehen was kann können wir erreichen und
das erfordert natürlich eine
rückeroberung erfordert viel viel mehr
kräfte von auf seiten der der ukraine
das können wir nicht bringen und ich
noch einen punkt noch zum zum anlass der
der diskussion oder der
die erreichung eines waffenstillstands
der muss natürlich verbunden sein mit
einer lösung die für die russen in
irgendeiner weise ein eine eine lösung
ist die akzeptabel ist wie auch immer
ist die frage muss das so sein dass man
dass die russen was adaptieren kann ja
also ich selber habe in der richtung
auch bei phoenix nicht in dieser runde
vor einiger zeit argumentiert dass ich
gesagt habe man muss punkten einen
gesichtswahrenden ausstieg ja genau das
ist das aber ich muss ihnen heute aus
der erfahrung und aus der kenntnis von
heute muss ich ihnen widersprechen muss
es einfach aus dem grunde widersprechen
weil putin sich diesen gesichtswahrenden
ausgang selbst verschlossen hat mit der
aggression hat dass ich den silber
selber die tür zugeschlagen und ich
glaube da pflicht ich auch meinen
deutschen freunden und anderen
nato-staaten mit buy ich glaube dass
tatsächlich die einzige sprache die
putin versteht eine harte sprache ist
die ihm deutlich zeichnen wir werden
nicht nachgeben und auf diese art und
weise kommt er vielleicht irgendwann zur
besinnung wo ich befürchte dass er das
auch nicht tun
da stimme ich zu das wollte ich noch
einmal auf die türkei schauen weil das
ja auch ein richtiger kurze frage ja
gegenüber wen muss man denn die gesicht
bewahren gegenüber westen die art der
tanz schon seit langem dass verloren
gegenüber
und gegenüber eigene bevölkerung kann er
jedes böse in einer erklärung die
glauben alles das heißt er kann sagen
ich habe das krieg gewonnen und da
werden etwas genommen auch wenn die
creme verliert aber das wäre wie dieses
stillstand stattfinden muss ist nur
durch die ukraine zu bestimmen und nicht
durch haben wir uns nicht das ist
wichtig würde ganz gar noch die letzten
paar minuten aber nutzen weil wir auch
über die werte hier reden auch über die
nato als ein bündnis wo es ja auch um
die werte eben geht und es gab ja viel
diskussion mit der türkei eben über
diesen beitritt von schweden und
finnland hören wir mal was erdogan
präsident erdogan der heute noch
zugesagt hatte in schweden und in
finnland sind terrororganisationen und
in dieser hinsicht hat die türkei auch
seine rote linien zum ausdruck gebracht
wir haben
unsere sensibilitäten aus zum ausdruck
gebracht und wir sind konstruktiv
herangetreten an unsere bündnis
passender dann hat aber auch jetzt
gesagt wenn das nicht passiert also zum
beispiel auslieferung von den menschen
die ihr terroristen nimmt von der pkk
dass der dann eventuell das parlament
dann gar nicht zustimmen kann 4000 die
bewerten sie das wenn erdogan somit der
nato und
als sträflich und als ich vor allen
dingen von seiten der nato empfinde ich
das als mit zweierlei maß messen erdogan
hat gegen die syrische pkk an nur die
gpg hatte ja schon kriege geführt und
seine seiner absicht ist den ort
streifen von syrien ganz zu säubern und
die syrischen flüchtlinge dort
anzusiedeln das hat ganz oft schon
erklärt das weiß man und der geht
schritt für schritt vorher ist weder
schwedische nicht nur deutsche sondern
auch schwedisch oder vielleicht findet
oder weiß ich amerikanische flugzeuge
bilder haben damit er das umsetzen kann
und die regierung erdogan
geht dadurch in ein anderes land um ihre
kriegsziele durchzusetzen und das ich
weiß nicht was das mit völkerrecht zu
tun hat und das machte nato mitglied und
alle anderen schweigen ja das ist schon
das ist schon krass er wäre sie sehen
sie das hat die nato sich dazu sehr den
forderungen von eltern gebaut
also was die terroristen an geht
möglicherweise nicht denn wir dürfen ja
auch nicht vergessen dass beispielsweise
die pkk auf der internationalen terror
liste der vereinten nationen darauf
stehen als terroristische organisation
ich weiß jetzt nicht wie das im
augenblick mit der jbs rückstand pgs ob
die auf dieser liste auch draufstehen
entzieht sich meiner kenntnis zweite
aussage wir haben auch amerikanische
soldaten in nordsyrien gehabt die dort
dafür gesorgt haben oder sorgen sollten
dass die truppen von assad dort nicht
ich sag das mal einen vernichtungskrieg
geführt haben oder führen sollten und
wir haben damit auch zum teil das war ja
auch ein risiko werden diese
auseinandersetzung sogar die gefahr
gehabt dass wir dort möglicherweise
amerikanischen truppen gegen russische
truppen aufeinander hätten treffen
lassen können was auch zu einer
besonderen eskalation geführt hat
trotzdem um auf ihre frage
zurückzukommen
die türkei ist kein einfacher
bündnispartner dieses mal so schlicht
und einfach formuliert und es ist immer
ein abwägen man kann ja auch über werte
man kann über demokratie die veränderung
der verfassung durch ein erdogan kann
man reden es wäre halt schön wenn die
türkei sich in der richtung mehr an die
menschenrechte erhalten würde und auch
mehr an demokratische grundregeln halten
würde nur sie tut es nicht und dann wird
abgewogen mit der strategischen
bedeutung digital von die hard ist frank
hat und auch für den zugang zum nahen
und mittleren osten das entscheidet man
sich zumindest bis heute dann halt eben
zu gunsten der türkei das ist eine
situation der akt um diesen faktor wir
können es doch gar nicht mehr ausgehen
weil nicht mehr viel zeit haben und
würde ich gerne eine letzte runde noch
eine kurze runde noch mit ihnen machen
würde das g20 außenministertreffen es
den indonesien schon nächste woche wenn
man noch mal vor ausschaut und guckt
diplomatie verhandlungen herr terrace
sehen sie irgendeine chance wo sie sagen
da gibt es irgend könnte irgendwas
positives sein dass dieser krieg in der
ukraine an beendet werden kann
ich sehe da die möglichkeit heute nicht
leute nicht dass die einzige möglichkeit
die verhandlungen waren schon da also
man hat
versucht ihn anzurufen und putin nimmt
nicht ab deshalb desktop ist die
verhandlungen nicht sind die werte nicht
möglich und das heißt dies dieses glück
wird aus dem renault logos entschieden
sehen sie eine chance
ich glaube nein also wenn ich dafür
plädieren dass man diplomatisch aktiver
ist und da hat wirklich haben die usa
den den dienst zentralen part zu spielen
um etwas zu erreichen denn sie werden
oder die großen erwarten auf augenhöhe
mit den usa wahrgenommen zu werden ich
sehe es aber im augenblick nicht dass
das geschehen wird aber trotzdem sollte
man sich davon nicht abhalten lassen und
versuchen dort rasen also ich kann mich
da nur herrn lüdeking anschließen das
wirklich schnell passieren kann und die
usa und russland müssen zusammen sitzen
und müssen gucken wo auf welchen ebenen
sie ein bisschen näher aneinander wieder
kommen können um
wirklich in richtung
diplomatische lösungen für die ukraine
zu kommen kurz antwort von ihnen also
ich hoffe dass es eine gelegenheit gibt
wo der außenminister blinken und der
außenminister lawrow bei dem
außenministertreffen vielleicht noch mit
frau berbalk dabei gemeinsam reden
können und ich bin fest davon überzeugt
dass alle drei wenn sie eine chance
haben die chance nutzen werden aber wenn
das diese chance wollen dann geht das
wäre an etwas positiver ausblick hoffen
wir mal dass so weit kommt vielen dank
herr terrace herr lüdeking frau klausen
und drums für den besuch hier und die
diskussion und ihnen natürlich auch
vielen dank fürs zuschauen und jetzt
gibt es geht weiter mit phoenix der tag
und da sehen sie auch noch mal jede
menge vom nato gipfel bis dahin tschüss